[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
ça va quand même avec les mecs ça ira
dans quelques instants ce sera la
rencontre entre les 6 garçons et les 5
filles
[Applaudissements]
Kamel qui est avec nous dans la saison 2
exactement
je voudrais juste qu'on voit cet extrait
qui a fait ta légende c'est le plus cool
regardez c'était incroyable ça va
attends tu es fan d'aromat maintenant ah
maintenant je les connais toutes hein tu
peux me faire un quiz il y a pas de
problème
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
laisse tomber c'est pendant longtemps ça
m'a suivi c'était presque devenu mon nom
de famille tu vois moi je marchais dans
la rue des gens me disaient c'est Kamel
team et tout ça alors que même ma mère
et mon père ils m'ont appelé petit maman
[Rires]
c'était pas fait exprès on a remarqué
aussi que sur ta saison
les candidates elles étaient pas hyper
bonne en conjugaison en français vous
avez des problèmes de conjugaison
d'accord heureusement que tu as continué
la phrase parce que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là il a il est parti
merde ça avait l'air bon c'était quoi ça
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
quand tu sors du loft après c'est ça
faisait combien de temps donc ça ça fait
quoi ça
après bah après j'étais sur M6 ouais on
m'avait proposé d'être chroniqueur sur
la version après-midi de Morning life
c'est ça qui s'appelait selfter on a
fait ça pendant un mois donc j'étais
super content sur le plateau on m'a dit
voilà le directeur de programme m'a dit
voilà je t'offre
ta carrière à la télévision tu vas être
chroniqueur sur M6 et c'est le début
d'une grande aventure on a fait un mois
et après ça s'est arrêté
ça va pas ça va pas faire du bien
Delphine
mais
c'était la folie c'était vraiment la
folie vaut mieux un mois de folie que 10
ans de merde c'est vrai alors il y avait
aussi des problèmes de conjugaison dans
la saison 2 après tu vas nous dire ce
que tu as fait après regardez
j'ai vu pour moi c'est pas un génie je
te jure parce que moi
c'est pas ça mais pourquoi ça fait deux
joyeuses alors regarde coup de foudre ou
sauvage patient tu vois c'est un peu
style le contraire je crois que un génie
c'est stupide moi je crois que c'est le
contraire un génie quelqu'un t'es
ingénué à génie il y a génial et un
c'est le contraire non et après
ingénieur ingénieur pour moi c'est le
contraire pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
être intelligent mais peut-être que tu
as raison
mais juste après et aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui moi je fais du stand-up
d'accord je joue sur plein de petites
scènes parisiennes je suis en train
d'écrire mon spectacle ça fait 20 ans
que je dis que je reprends des camions
spectacle mais là j'y suis ça y est
c'est bon je fais plein de petites
scènes parisiennes et justement je sur
scène je parle de tout ça en fait parce
que à chaque fois que je monte sur des
petites scènes parisiennes les gens
regardent mais genre c'est qui parce que
ils oublient un peu c'est pas c'est qui
ce mec c'est pas le mec qui m'a dépanner
dans le périph c'est pas le mec qui a
une épicerie en bas de chez moi et à un
moment donné je leur dis voilà peut-être
ma tête vous dit quelque chose et j'ai
fait la story il y a 20 ans 10 millions
de téléspectateurs parce qu'à l'époque
c'était c'était la folie de beaucoup
mais bien sûr je me rappelle de Benjamin
excellent présentateur vraiment
excellent
il était bon il était bon parce que il
était il se prêtait il était jamais
sérieux en fait quand c'est action on
était sérieux quand il disait couper et
là ça y est c'était ça partait
action il faisait l'émission quand tu
les écoutes
exactement
ça m'a été à gratter des places ça
marche bien pour toi parce que tu gagnes
bien ta vie est-ce que tu es content
pourquoi par rapport au reste non non
mais d'accord ce que j'allais dire bah
aujourd'hui c'est difficile
tu aurais eu la même vie qu'aujourd'hui
ça avait pas fait le loft est-ce que ça
t'arrange je pense pas mais après c'est
c'est marrant parce que aujourd'hui moi
j'ai une vie totalement ordinaire
c'est-à-dire que j'ai une vie de famille
j'habite toujours en province là où j'ai
grandi j'ai une petite maison donc voilà
j'ai une petite familiale voiture
familiale donc j'ai une vie totalement
ordinaire et si j'avais pas fait loft je
pense que j'aurais cette même vie mais
par contre j'aurais pas vécu toutes les
belles choses que j'ai pu vivre à
travers
ou pas ah non je regrette pas je
regrette pas je regrette jamais ce que
je fais tu faisais quoi avant le loft
j'étais enfin je voulais être chauffeur
de bus d'accord et tu regardes pas
d'abord c'est un truc de ouf
juste il y a une autre candidat qui
était un personnage emblématique de la
saison 2 du love c'est Afida puisque il
le bluff liste de revenir sur les
antennes très vite ça brise de partout
je le sens que ça va arriver très très
vite safida qu'on l'a vu dans le mag
juste avant à l'époque elle se faisait
appeler Leslie mais elle était déjà à
FIDA regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ben du coup en version publique déjà
Benjamin c'est déjà une star
écoutez Benjamin c'est les meute chez
nous elle va retrouver bientôt ses amis
[Applaudissements]
écoutez c'est quand même incroyable
c'est un accueil de stars digne des plus
grandes
de revenir c'est incroyable Benjamin
Castaldi c'est une bonne idée alors moi
c'est une excellente idée je pense que
ça a l'argent sa place faut savoir que à
l'époque il y avait pas les réseaux
aujourd'hui avec la puissance des
réseaux d'Instagram de Tic-Toc etc si le
probable il est relayé et que toutes les
écoles c'est qu'il y a je pense des
séquences interdites à l'antenne qu'on
pourra mettre en plus ou en payant je
pense ça va très très marcher et je
pense qu'il y a une vraie nostalgie et
ça fait quand même 20 ans qu'il y a pas
eu un vrai programme on est enfermé on a
vu des dérivés on a vu des émissions ils
étaient un peu dedans un peu de Rocket
là c'est un problème qu'on appelle du
container ils sont enfermés sans
téléphone coupé du monde cette personne
est horrible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Benjamin Castaldi on vous a fait une
compil des comptes des Quotidiennes
franchement moi je l'ai trouvé je le
trouvais très bon et non franchement
bravo frère non vraiment c'est c'est
génial en plus d'avoir un menton pareil
le menton c'est c'est non mais il est
plus comme ça j'ai dû le raboter un
menton frère on dirait une table de
ping-pong
à l'époque elle est pas paradis mais les
gens nommés les Daltons ah ouais à cause
du menton
n'hésitez pas à échanger vos impressions
de le sur les merde nous dit lovecteurs
ont pris le soin de revêtir leurs amis
dans ce qu'on appelle le confessionnal
bois Fabrice et tout de suite bien sûr
bien intégré et on peut avancer un petit
peu merci parce que je ne vois pas ce
qui était escrime merci vous avez vu
tout à l'heure qu'il répétait une scène
du film culte non la Vérité si je mens
et les Bronzés font du ski
je trouve ça scandaleux moi qui ne me
trompe jamais moi qui fait mes plateaux
d'une traite comme dirait-on quelques
couleurs chacun profitant
ça allait ou pas
[Applaudissements]
j'étais pas du tout animateur vedette
j'étais chroniqueur j'étais j'étais sur
TF1 je suis célébrités et en fait
l'histoire je l'ai raconté ma femme et
je vais vous la raconter une énième fois
personne voulait animer ce programme
c'est quand ils sont venus me chercher
tout Paris avait refusé mais tout Paris
et comme moi à l'époque c'était déjà en
séparation et donc en train de divorcer
je me suis dit quand même que je suis un
petit peu la suite et j'avais dégoûté je
veux bien faire ce petit programme
comme un programme sociétal à la base
j'ai surtout ce que je voudrais c'est un
petit contrat pour la rentrée parce que
là l'émission je vais la faire mais ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la suite et après
évidemment ça a été ce que ça a été mais
j'étais j'étais lancé comme ça c'est
incroyable tu as la petite larmichette
ah c'est bon alors un c'est beaucoup
d'émotion ça me replonge 20 ans en
arrière les enfants étaient tout petits
je venais de me marier j'allais mariner
divorcer j'allais me marier vraiment
changé
avec tes petits
à l'époque j'ai été et vraiment protégé
parce que j'ai eu la chance de pas me
rendre compte de ce que je vivais sinon
j'aurais je pense péter les plombs parce
que c'était un truc de fou et la chaîne
pour le coup bah vraiment protégé mes
proches vont protéger j'ai vraiment pas
vu le phénomène que c'était avant 3 4 5
semaines donc merci merci à eux et merci
de m'avoir fait confiance on va avoir un
autre soleil les gagnants pouvaient
gagner des chèques de 250000 €. donc
c'était gros enjeux on va regarder la
finale c'est aussi qu'on comprend
l'engouement qu'il y avait autour de
l'émission regardez c'était fou
qui sort vainqueur de cet extraordinaire
aventure qui a été love story pendant
près de 70 jours et Christophe et Loana
[Applaudissements]
c'est la sortie de tous les lobsters
avec les vainqueurs sachahute énormément
ça bouge de beaucoup mais rassurez-vous
on va les emmener très rapidement vers
leur voiture ils vont monter deux par
deux c'est le délire il y a au moins je
sais pas mais il y a facilement dans les
rues maintenant au moins après 1000 1500
personnes et ça arrive de partout je
crois que tout le monde s'est fait
passer le mot et maintenant folie
[Applaudissements]
sur les antennes très vite Benjamin
c'est comme vous combien vous payez pour
la saison la première saison alors la
première saison j'ai été payé je vais
vous dire tout 300000 francs
et la deuxième j'avais demandé un
million de France quoi
c'était le début c'est le début là
c'était le début j'ai acheté une maison
petite maison tu as demandé quoi tu es
passé de
300000 francs parlent en France
50000 à 300000 bah oui bah je vais comme
vous savez
je me suis vendu
la question c'est retour du loss donc en
version pas Secret Story apparemment
loft d'accord donc il y a pas de secret
donc on verra il risque d'avoir Secret
Story qui revient ah oui peut-être sur
une plateforme et love story peut-être
sur une chaîne de télévision
ça va être bizarre parce que maintenant
il y a les réseaux sociaux il y a les
réseaux les gens
et les gens quand ils rentrent
maintenant dans une émission t'arrêter
parce que moi j'ai fait love story mais
derrière j'ai fait les Anges de la télé
et moi j'ai bien vu le le changement
et même après quand on m'a proposé
d'autres émissions j'ai refusé parce que
c'était rien à voir l'off c'était on
était innocence
honnêtement je suis rentré je savais
même pas ce qui m'attendait j'ai vu bon
j'ai vu Leslie
Afida quoi
je suis resté en 2002 mais j'ai vu un
filetage j'ai dit ah ouais d'accord
c'est ça et tout donc moi
[Rires]
c'était la folie avant mais là
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux je sais pas
si ça va donner la même chose alors je
pense pas moi je pense moi
Julie et Christophe c'est le premier
couple en France à s'être rencontré dans
une émission télé-réalité ou encore
ensemble 19h56
risque de devenir redevenir on pense euh
Secret Story sur une plateforme love
story sur une chaîne de télévision je
pense que ça va arriver très très vite
après mon pif légendaire regardez
on pourrait faire quelque chose je pense
mais je sais pas j'aimerais attendre
d'avoir un peu plus de sentiments pour
que ce soit un peu plus
sérieuse tu veux ça vienne un peu plus
de lacs
que de là
[Musique]
heureusement que que mon petit
Christophe hier soir quand même c'est
vrai que ça soulagement quoi
c'est bien oui c'est c'est sympathique
en plus elle était pas elle était pas
trop bas c'était assez haute donc on
avait assez de place et c'était bien
ça c'est le plus beau cadeau que j'ai là
tu vois
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu forcément pas mal de classe
dans cette émission attention c'est la
première c'était la première fois qu'on
voyait des gens s'embrouiller comme ça à
la télé avant à la télé personne
s'embrouiller c'est vrai et c'était la
première fois vous voyez vraiment des
embrouilles totalement je me rappelle
même mon daron regardez le 24 24
love story il me disait pourquoi il
m'avait dit à l'époque pourquoi tu fais
pas de la télé j'ai dit non je laisse ça
au compte
que je vais être tout seul quoi arrêtez
de pénétration véhicules machin et tout
je vous donne mon avis parce que là je
le sens maintenant comme ça donc tout de
suite parce que ça lourde vous entendez
le cul comme ça
moi je te respecte alors tu me respectes
ta gueule
tu laisses la porte ouverte pas
pour qui celle-là peut-être mais tu la
fermes doucement
c'est en général ce que j'ai sur le
coeur en général je la garde pas tu vois
donc je crois que je vais te le dire
avant que avant que tu partes je suis
pas une marchandise et je suis pas là
vraiment un petit con quoi c'est toi qui
sait pas parler ok
qui m'énerve la Christophe là
il peut pas fermer sa gueule un peu
mal là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très très bon personnage très bon
casting
qui avait remplacé une connerie qui
était parti au tout début et là je m'en
rappelle plus
il y avait aussi des grosses rigolade à
l'époque les candidats n'avaient pas de
filtre comme disait Kamel on espère que
si ça revient ils ont autant de pluie
voilà c'est ça ça donnait des phrases
complètement culte regardez
qui c'est qui a pété
je trouve que il a plutôt aucune
personnalité c'est plus Fabrice ces gens
Édouard II
regardez ce qu'elle vient de chier là
bas
[Musique]
et hypocrite
pour avoir les pets comme ça
[Musique]
vous pouvez essayer de l'aider par mot
franchement moi il me broute les
couilles quoi c'est clair quoi
tu m'as invité mais tu as mis que des
extraits du loft 1 j'ai l'impression que
tout refusé
1 et voilà c'était nouveau il voulait
dire ah ouais d'accord c'était nouveau
dans les équipes et je me rappelle comme
c'était des artistes et tout ça me
rappelle un peu nous maintenant genre
quand voilà c'est on est un peu les
relous de l'époque en fait et on se fait
non mais c'est pas possible pas des mecs
du loft quoi nous on écrit on est dans
notre délire tu vois on peut pas mettre
des mecs comme ça tu vois nous on est
des artistes tu vois nous notre texte on
veut qu'il soit tu vois vraiment la
virgule près donc ça a été un
déferlement j'aurais dit même pas en
rêve il y a un mec qui vient de du loft
et je crois qu'il y a eu un mec qui est
venu je crois c'est Philippe
et il est venu c'était l'intello il a
exactement il a fait un mois avec nous à
comédie et genre le pauvre voilà et en
plus c'est personne lui parler genre
c'était un peu genre
tu me dégoûtes Cyril vraiment
ressaisis-toi je me rappelle et moi il y
a un mec un jour je veux que c'est moi
je faisais aussi je faisais du théâtre
en même temps quand j'étais stagiaire et
la prof elle a dit un moment un jour
elle est venue me voir elle a dit dans
les élèves arrêtez de toute façon
Hanouna il terminera sur M6
bon bah elle s'est pas trompé je suis
allé sur M6 en plus pas longtemps après